after over three decades working as a
carer moira's health began to suffer
begetting her through it was known
retirement at 60 was Round the Corner
except what she and 3.8 million women
born in the 50s weren't told was the
state pension age had risen with no time
to prepare she suddenly learned she had
to work for six more years it was
devastating absolutely devastating
physical and mentally it was really
struggling really struggling to work and
also lots of my friends died at 60 so
they never got their pension so not only
that I'm thinking am I ever going to see
this pension because am I going to live
to be 66 nobody knows
after years of campaigning last year the
Parliamentary Ombudsman found these
women should have been given more notice
for women like Moira it could have made
a huge difference to their lives data
shared exclusively with Sky News found
almost a third of women affected are in
debt eighty percent of those surveyed
said they had suffered financial
hardship by the delay in finding out the
age of retirement had moved and over 220
000 women affected have died without
answers many of them Angela knew
personally and it's for them she
continues to fight for answers the
government has never really engaged with
us guy oppermann the last pensions
Minister said he last met with com waspy
campaign in 2016
which really is atrocious given that we
have lost so much through government
incompetence the department for work and
pensions says it prioritizes supporting
people to get the help they are entitled
to and point to both the high court and
court of appeal judgments which support
their actions on the issue for a
generation of women their weight for
compensation ticks on as they can't
shake the feeling of Injustice
ashnaharanag Sky News